salut heureusement ça oui oui oui mais
ton t-shirt la série jeudi pour changer
un peu du noir je mette un tee shirt
rouge qui pèse bien toi a même pas vous
savez peut-être parce que j'en ai déjà
parlé dans une faq et sur les réseaux
sociaux je suis daltonien
ça va passer de gueule on n'en meurt pas
c'est même très vivable
d'ailleurs le daltonisme c'est pas
vraiment une maladie c'est une disque
roma topsy c'est à dire une anomalie de
la perception des couleurs elle doit son
nom au chimiste et physicien britannique
john dalton qui l'a décrite en 1794
après s'être rendu compte que son frère
et lui ne voyez pas les mêmes couleurs
que toulon et depuis on sait comment ça
marche
vous voulez savoir aussi c'est ça bon
les récepteurs chargé de la vision des
couleurs ça s'appelle les cônes on en a
entre 5 et 7 millions dans la rétine
c'est à dire là tout au fond de l'oeil
et quand les rayons lumineux arrive
jusqu'à eux ils sont excités par les
différentes longueurs d'onde qui
correspondent aux différentes couleurs
on est dit donc c'est pas du verre que
je vois la barre et sa lutte à l'opti
rouge elle c'est à toi cette belle
longueur d'onde là et on double ses
blues une appli
oui les coins c'est un peu des bouffes
c'est comme ça il y a trois sortes de
caunes qui contiennent chacun un pigment
qui réagit à une couleur spécifique les
aces qui correspondent aux bleus les
aime au vert et les ailes au rouge
ils sont plus ou moins excité en
fonction de la lumière colorée renvoyé
par l'objet qu'on regarde il transforma
en signal électrique qu'ils envoient au
cortex dans le cerveau qui analyse les
infos et détermine de quelle couleur
il s'agit chez les daltoniens un de ces
pigments est absent ou déficient et la
vision de la couleur concernés et de
toutes les nuances dans laquelle elle
est présente et plus ou moins perturbées
donc en fonction des communes concernées
et de l'importance de l'atteinte
on a plusieurs formes de daltonisme sans
surprise les plus fréquents ça touche le
rouge
si c'est le pigment rouge qui est
atteint vous êtes pro tannock et si les
déficients vous êtes protat normal ou
protano mal on va garder la version sans
le mot anormal si c'est le pigment vert
qui est en cause vous êtes 2 tera knock
ou 2 tera normal alors ça veut pas dire
que vous voyez pas du tout le rouge ou
vert ça veut dire que vous voyez pas ou
que vous voyez mal les longueurs d'onde
dans lesquels sont situés la majorité de
ses couleurs mais comme vous le voyez
sur le schéma on peut quand même s'en
sortir avec les autres comme moins bien
et on peut il ya aussi des cas beaucoup
plus rares comme la tri tanoh pie ou la
trith anomalie qui touche les pigments
bleus des cônes ou la croate occident
laquelle deux types de cônes ou les
trois sont touchés du coup dans ce
dernier cas vous voyez tout en niveaux
de gris au noir et blanc
si vous voulez ça donne un petit côté
vintage mais au quotidien c'est pas
pratique
oui et bien sûr c'est pas contagieux ça
peut être causée par des traumatismes ou
des maladies qui abîment l'oeil ou le
cortex
mais dans l'immense majorité des cas
c'est héréditaire
le gène du daltonisme il est situé sur
le chromosome x et il est récessif nous
explique les hommes ont un chromosome x
reçu de leur mère et un promo hommes y
reçu de leur père alors que les femmes
ont deux chromosomes x
un reçu de leur mère un refus de leur
père jusqu'ici c'est bon alors pour
qu'un homme soit daltonien il suffit
qu'ils reçoivent l'anomalie de sa mère
parce qu'il a qu'un pro monique alors
que pour qu'une femme soit daltonienne
il faut qu'ils reçoivent l'anomalie de
ses deux parents parce que sinon le bon
prono zone il compense donc vous
entendrez souvent dire que le daltonisme
est transmis par la mère à son fils
n'est pas complètement faux mais ce qui
est pas tout à fait vrai non plus
d'abord parce que mon frère est pas
daltonien alors que moi oui donc c'est
pas à tous les coups ensuite parce que
l'anomalie de la vision des couleurs ça
touche 8 % des hommes dans le monde mais
aussi 0 5% des femmes
alors comment est ce qu'on se rend
compte qu'on est daltonien souvent c'est
un peu par hasard et c'est toujours un
moment désagréable voire un peu millions
ou alors c'est chez le médecin ou à
l'école quand on vous fait passer un
test de la vision des couleurs
spécifiques comme celui qui a été
inventé en 1917 par shinobu ishihara en
japonais en gros on vous montre un
cercle qui est formé d'une multitude de
petites pastilles de couleurs
différentes et vous vous devez dire le
chiffre que vous voyez à l'intérieur
suivant votre vision des couleurs est
normal ou pas vous voyez pas le même
chiffre suivant type d'anomalie que vous
avez vous voyez parfois le bon chiffre
parfois le mauvais et parfois rien du
tout et des fois aussi vous voyez une
forme qui n'est pas un chiffre genre un
éléphant ça m'est arrivé je peux vous
dire c'est un peu humiliant aussi vous
voyez quoi comme chiffres un éléphant
si vous avez envie d'être fixé vous
pouvez faire le test vieira y perd
facilement sur internet
bon maintenant qu'on sait comment ça
marche on va passer à la partie
éducative et il ya du boulot
c'est quelle couleur ça s'il vous plaît
arrêtez de faire ça d'abord parce que ça
donne l'impression qu'on est un fric
qu'on ait regardé dans sa cage à la
foire et que c'est chiant ensuite parce
que 9 fois sur 10 vous montrer une
bouteille de coca et on sait tous que
c'est rouge même si on est daltonien
et en plus quand on a la bonne réponse
on enchaîne quasiment à tous les coups
sûrs
bah tu vois les couleurs étaient pas la
taille là oui quand on est daltonien
on voit des couleurs c'est juste que
suivant le type de daltonisme pour les
voit pas tout où on distingue pas toutes
les nuances où on en profond certaine
mais des fois on a bon quand même
donc à moins d'être accro matt up
complet on voit des couleurs mais on est
quand même bateau bah c'est pas dur
quand il voit rouge tunique sévère mais
merci einstein à la tu viens de changer
la vue de tous les daltoniens du monde
enterre génie parce que personne n'y
avait pensé avant mais non quand un
daltonien voit une couleur parfois ils
voient la bonne parce qu'elle est située
dans le spectre est là pas de problème
parfois ils voient la mauvaise parce
qu'elle est située sur ne respecte donc
donc ça marche pas comme ça c'est pas un
vrai régal rouge et rouge égales vers
des opa léger mais tu vois comment en
fait par celle là c'est juste impossible
d'y répondre en atteignant il voit comme
il a toujours vu donc il a aucun élément
de comparaison
maintenant vous le savez c'est une
histoire de nuances et de spectre
lumineux donc c'est indescriptible moyen
des visuels qui propose de montrer
comment voix à les différents types de
daltoniens leurs vêtements ok allez je
vous montre
ça c'est la façon dont je vois un oeil
non daltonien ça c'est ce que voit 1-2
terrano mal ça c'est ce que voit 1-2
tehran hop ça c'est ce que voit un
protano mal ça c'est ce que voit improta
nope ça c'est ce que voit un tri tanoh
mal ça c'est ce que voit un tri tan up
et ça donc c'est ce que voit un acrobate
hop voilà comme ça tout le monde est
content mais bon en vrai comme on peut
savoir que c'est la réalité
moi je peux pas vous confirmer que c'est
ce que je vois pas ce que cette image là
je la vois avec ma propre vision des
couleurs qui est déjà des formes et il
ya personne qui est jamais revenu de
l'autre côté du daltonisme pour dire ah
oui c'est comme ça que ce soit y avait
d'ailleurs c'est quoi les vraies
couleurs
vous êtes sûr vous que toulouse voit
exactement la même chose si c'était si
facile les couleurs on n'aurait pas
inventé lé nom à la con pour les décrire
genre tôt caca d'oie oiseaux l'un ceci
ça existe dans nos lancers du violet je
crois bon vous avez compris daltoniens
c'est les tracas au quotidien à cause
des métiers qu'on n'a pas droit de faire
comme pilote de ligne par exemple à
cause des codes couleurs qu'on nous met
partout et pour choisir ses slips c'est
vrai que c'est moins gênant
en attendant a alors vous avez aussi
sans doute vu ces vidéos extrêmement
touchante de daltoniens qui voit les
couleurs pour la première fois grâce à
des lunettes correctrices spéciale eh
ben il se trouve que je me suis procuré
un de ces objets magiques et que je me
propose de les tester pour vous dans une
prochaine vidéo
du coup bas mais compris on voit ce
qu'ils étaient là pour aujourd'hui mais
on se retrouve très très vite
alors d'içi là comme d'habitude mettez
vous bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]